- Yeah. Yeah, I got multiple
notifications on LinkedIn
that people working in the
prime minister's office
were looking at my profile.
More than once I got
these notifications.
And the first time I was like,
"Okay, what does that mean?"
Then the second time
and the third time.
And it was clear to me
that I had said some things
that were not so good for
their public relations team.
(suspenseful music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today is
the Substack essayist
for "Noble Truths with
Rav Arora" and journalist
who I don't have to
put air quotes around.
It's quite lovely.
Rav Arora, welcome back
to "The Rubin Report."
- Hey, Dave.
It's good to be on,
and it's good to get that formal
"Noble Truths with Rav
Arora" introduction.
I'm still working
on that branding,
but I like the way you said
it, for sure. Appreciate it.
- "Noble Truths with Rav
Arora," it sounds pleasant
and lofty and really
the highest compliment
that I can give
someone these days
the fact that I can
call you a journalist
and I didn't have
to do air quotes.
I mean, does it get
any better than that?
- Yeah. Yeah.
And I don't have any
formal education.
So, for some people that
evokes a lot of skepticism
about who this weirdo writing
in his mom's basement is,
but I think for a lot of people,
I just kind of just
say what I wanna say.
And I'm just straight
with the facts
and I don't try to spin it
according to any kind of
precondition narrative.
I'm not working for anybody.
I'm just writing about issues
that are important to me.
And I don't really identify
as liberal or conservative,
just kind of trying to
make sense of the world,
whatever comes my way.
And if that means I'm
gonna sound a little left
on something or a little
right, I just go for it.
- Well, Rav, I would
rather have a weirdo
in his mom's
basement than someone
that went to Columbia
Journalism School,
so you are good to go.
Most of my audience
probably recognizes you.
You've been on the show
for multiple Friday
panel extravaganzas,
but you do find work
as a journalist.
You are up in Canada.
And the reason I wanted to do
this condensed interview
with you today,
and we're just sort of
shooting this on the fly
is because you've gotten
into some hot water
with your prime minister up
there in Canada, Justin Trudeau.
In my estimation is
the most authoritarian,
I would say world leader
from a Western nation.
And you've been
writing a bit about him
and what's going on in Canada.
And now the government
is looking into you.
You scary person in
your mom's basement.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know why
I'm so threatening.
I mean, I don't know, my mom
has been funny about this
and I can talk about
that in a second.
But yeah, I wrote an op-ed
in the "New York Post"
calling Trudeau basically a
horrible authoritarian leader
who's violated basic human
rights, civil liberties
and constitutional rights,
specifically with respect
to the vaccine mandates.
And I just talked about how
my family were
immigrants from India
and we came to Canada in
search for more freedom.
Whether that's financial,
social, political, vocational.
We just wanted
more opportunities.
And that was kind of the idea
that my mom and my dad had,
is to give us more
freedoms, right?
Give their kids more freedom,
so they can pursue
what they wanna pursue.
And here we are during
the COVID pandemic.
And, yes, there are many issues
surrounding keeping people safe,
keeping vulnerable people safe.
And there are various
restrictions that
perhaps make sense.
But when it came
to just my freedom,
it was completely restricted.
I couldn't go to the gym
for the longest time,
for several months.
Couldn't go out to a
restaurant and dine in,
and I couldn't
even travel by air.
I couldn't even fly
or go on a train
anywhere in the country,
let alone leave the country
for several months due to
the travel vaccine mandates
that outright discriminated,
outright banned
the unvaccinated from
traveling anywhere,
other than if you
wanna go in your car.
But even that you couldn't
cross the US-Canada border.
And I missed out on a
lot of opportunities.
Like in December, for example
I was talking to
Ben Shapiro's team.
I've been on a
show a couple times
and we were thinking about
doing something in Florida
actually at the time in person.
And I just couldn't go
because I was banned.
I was deemed as a
second-class citizen
who was not able to travel.
And so, in this
article that I wrote,
I just made that
point of in many ways
my freedoms would've been
more secured in India,
the country that I
came from than here.
Even though we came
here for more freedoms.
And that to me is
just a total travesty
and really makes us reevaluate
what this supposedly
free liberal democracy
here in Canada,
where our freedoms are
completely restricted.
- So, you write the piece
in the "New York Post."
And of course,
nothing you're saying
is coming as a
surprise to my audience
because obviously
we've covered a lot
of what's going on with
Trudeau and Canada,
the trucker convoy and
freezing of bank accounts,
and all of that stuff.
So, I think everyone
watching this is on board.
They hear what you're saying.
But then how did
this thing level up?
You suddenly found
some government people
were doing a little
digging on you.
- Yeah, yeah.
I got multiple
notifications on LinkedIn
that people working in the
prime minister's office
were looking at my profile.
More than once I got
these notifications.
And the first time I was like,
"Okay, what does that mean?"
And the second time
and the third time.
And it was clear to me
that I had said some things
that were not so good for
their public relations team.
And I don't know who it
was that looked at me,
whether it was just
some 27-year-old intern
at the public relations office,
or whether it was
somebody higher up.
A lot of people think it's
somebody perhaps higher up,
who for them, like this is
really bad press, right?
And that's obviously
not my goal.
My goal is not to
just shit on Trudeau.
My goal is to just say
what I honestly wanna say
and talk about some of the
disturbing authoritarian trends
in this country.
And it seemed to have
rung an alarm for them
and they wanted to look into me,
and I don't know what the
implications of that is,
other than I'm on the
prime minister's radar.
And I should probably put
that on my Twitter bio.
(Dave laughing)
- It should be on
your Twitter bio
for as long as you're
allowed to be on Twitter.
I know a little something
about how tenuous that can be.
But can you just talk like
joking aside for a second?
Can you just talk about the
chilling effect of that?
I mean, look, you're
outspoken publicly.
You're a young person
trying to make your bones,
make your career.
You are publicly unvaxxed,
so you could not
leave the country.
You're critical
of the government.
And now you have government
agents in essence
looking closely at your work.
I mean, you're in your
mom's basement, as you said.
It's not the most fun
thing in the world.
- Yeah, yeah, no, some
people have mentioned to me
that I should take this a
bit more seriously than I am.
And I think that's
just my personality
is like, I don't take these
things super, super seriously
and lose sleep over them.
I mean, if Trudeau's
losing sleep over me,
that's fine enough.
(Dave laughing)
I don't wanna lose sleep over
making Trudeau lose sleep.
But no, in all seriousness,
it is very chilling
that one article can
have that kind of effect,
especially given that
I don't really have
like a massive platform yet.
I'm still growing.
I'm still a young person.
And I mean, even
just on Twitter too
with that article that I posted,
there were so many journalists,
government-funded
journalists by the way,
working for the CBC,
working for Global News,
the Toronto Star that were
pointing out that this op-ed
is total balderdash and he
should just get vaccinated,
and he just whining
about his freedoms.
And a lot of people, by the
way, weirdly enough were saying,
"Oh, he should just
go back to India.
Why is he even here?"
Like people like that
were saying and it's like,
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Why did we just go
like Trumpian suddenly?
Like, why?
Like I thought this
was the rhetoric
that was associated with Trump.
And then that was one of
the points of that essay
and a couple of other essays
that I've written before too.
It's like the direction we
went in, in the name of safety,
diversity, inclusivity.
It's exactly what we feared
would be of the other side.
Like Trudeau genuinely
has become this monstrous,
discriminatory
authoritarian leader
that we all feared
Trump would be.
And I'm no Trump defender.
I'm not gonna defend him
or openly support him,
or just any of that.
But what Trudeau is displaying
is true authoritarianism.
It's true stripping people away
from their constitutional rights
and their civil liberties.
And it's, when you're
a young journalist,
I'm definitely not part of
the conventional narrative,
because I'm not
writing for the "CBC."
I'm not writing for any of
these traditional outlets.
I'm just an independent writer.
And it seems to be,
there's a weird shortage
of that here in Canada.
Otherwise it's mysterious
why I've risen,
whereas other
journalists haven't.
It's like there aren't enough
independent journalists
who are willing to say
what I'm willing to say
because they rather get
their journalism degree
and work for the CBC and
get paid a certain salary
and spew out the same
political narrative
over and over again.
But for me, it's like
I don't want to be
anything close to that.
I want to be my own
independent voice
and raise these concerns
about my country.
- Yeah.
I mean, you bring up a
couple interesting things.
I mean, first this idea
that Trudeau in essence
has become what they
purported Trump to be.
Trump, it turned out not
to really be those things
for all his faults.
And now you've got Trudeau,
who's actually doing
many of those things
and he exercising
that state power,
but to your latter point
about these journalists
that go work for the
CBC and everything else.
You guys have a major
problem right now in Canada
that we don't
necessarily have here yet
or at least so obviously,
which is that the government
not only does fund a huge amount
of your journalism overtly.
Here, they do it more subtly.
But now independent
journalists like you
and Ezra Levant
over at the Rebel,
and a bunch of other people
that are trying to do some
interesting things in Canada
are gonna be held to sort
of untenable standards
when it comes to
your work, right?
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
There's a very small
minority of journalists
who are doing what
would me and Ezra.
And I'm trying to think who else
I would put in that category.
I mean, Rex Murphy writes
for the "National Post."
So, he writes for an
established outlet.
that's conservative leaning,
and he's been on
Jordan's podcast a bunch
to talk about Canadian politics.
But I think the
incentives are so stacked.
Like if you're a young
journalist, right?
My age or a bit older,
and you're conservative
leaning or libertarian leaning,
and you're really
dissatisfied with what
the government is
doing right now.
It's like why would you
ever want to do this?
Like, why would you ever want
get into this career path
where the odds are so
stacked against you,
that you, if you wanna
have a well-paying job,
if you wanna put food on
the table for your family,
you have to apply to the
CBC, the Toronto star
and you have to
continually perpetuate
and regurgitate these
same narratives,
otherwise you're not gonna
be making a lot of money.
I mean, even with
local outlets here,
like I live in a small
city called Chilliwack,
about an hour away
from Vancouver.
And the editor of the
"Chilliwack Progress."
He's openly called me like an
alt-right conspiracy theorist,
right-winger, somebody who's
covering for white people.
Like, he's openly blocked
me on all platforms.
He's called me alt-right
and the horrible names.
And it's like our
local newspaper, which
is thankfully dying
and it's not doing that well.
Even there, there's
a very established,
deep established narrative,
even though we live in a fairly
conservative area, actually.
But even the local
media outlets.
Let alone the
national, the federal,
the provincial level outlets.
They've also established
this given narrative.
And so, you have a lot of people
who might be interested
in becoming journalists,
but they just see that
that this is not gonna be
financially sustainable,
so then they become professors,
they become accountants,
or lawyers or
doctors or whatever.
That's just kind
of where it's at.
But so, it's very rare for
people like me who are young,
who have kind of
taken this risk.
And maybe because I'm young,
I'm more able to take
a bit of that risk
because I have certain freedoms
living with my parents still
and doing these kind of things,
where I can take these big risks
and speak out for
what I wanna say,
whereas other people
just financially,
given the media ecosystem,
just aren't able to.
- How much longer do
you think the situation
in Canada is sustainable?
I mean, look, you've got
people like Jordan Peterson,
who are outspoken critics
of the government.
And I think Jordan is
at least considering
leaving Canada all together.
Gad Saad, who of course,
professor at Concordia.
One of my best friends.
He is often talking
about leaving Canada.
Viva Frei, another big
actual journalist lawyer.
He just left.
He moved to Florida this week.
I mean, the brain drain
on a society like that
can't last forever.
- No, no.
Again, I've already
talked about journalism,
but it's same with academia.
You go, like even
my local university.
I've already mentioned
my local newspaper.
They hate me, the
local university.
There's also
professors there who...
There was one, a think tank
that I wanted to be part of
that was about having
young people talk
about real political issues,
particularly about race.
And I wanted to get into this.
And the professor
openly said to me like,
"No, no, you're not welcome."
Like, "We don't want
any of your views here."
The dominant narrative
within universities
it's so centralized.
It's so narrow-minded
that people who even
are outside of the norm,
they're immediately excluded
and they're immediately
marginalized.
So, there's this big
intellectual dominant force
that's very left-leaning
here in Canada
across universities.
And I'm not gonna say
like all universities
or everybody's like that.
There are wonderful
professors that I work with,
although more about like
religion or psychology,
or other things that aren't
as politically affected,
you might say.
But for journalists who
are coming up right now
and for people in
academia, in the humanities
and the liberal arts,
it's like there's an increasing
ideological monoculture
where you have to abide by
these certain religious precepts
with regards to gender,
with regards to race,
with regards to inequality,
with regards to
vaccination status.
And if you don't tow that line,
then you're immediately
an outsider.
And it's making
people like myself
think about
potentially moving too.
I don't know what will happen
but I think I'll
definitely wanna move here
at some point in the future.
- I don't know if you've heard
but the sun is
always shining here
in the free state of Florida.
- Hey, I would consider it.
I would genuinely consider that.
- All right.
We'll take this offline.
All right. Well, I wanted
to do this quickly with you,
just so that people
could hear about this
because you are fighting
the good fight up there.
I didn't know you were doing
it from your mom's basement.
Now, it seems doubly
cool what you're doing.
So, keep fighting
and we'll link to your
Substack down below,
so people can find you.
- Hey, it's a nice
basement here.
It's a nice basement.
- You got a window
in the basement.
I mean, that's pretty good.
- [Rav] I got a window.
- It's not like she's
just throwing fish heads
down there once a week.
- By the way, I'll just
quickly it say too,
like my mom has been very
fearful and discouraging me
from ever writing anything
bad about Trudeau.
She's been like, "Rav, do
we need bodyguards outside?"
Like, "You have little
siblings, Rav who go to school."
Like, "Don't ruin
their reputation
by being this like supposed
scary right-winger."
She's like, "Maybe we
have to move places
or change addresses."
Like, "Don't write anything
bad about Trudeau,"
in her very Indian
mom kind of way.
I'm like, "Mom, I'm
gonna move out."
And she's like, "Fine, do it."
And I'm like, "I'll
move with Dave Rubin
and look after his
kids in August maybe."
(Dave laughing)
- The only thing is we don't
have basements in Florida
because of the
storms, the flooding.
So, let me see what I can do.
I get back down that one.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
You gotta expose to
some racial diversity.
They need to see some brown.
They need to see
some brown faces.
(Dave laughing)
- Indeed. Indeed.
All right, Rav. Keep
up the good work, man.
- [Rav] All right. Thanks.
(suspenseful music)
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out the full episode playlist.
They're both right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.